if you're somebody that just became an
entrepreneur you just got into cells I
want to talk to you for two minutes here
today listen when I first chose to go
into the world of sales when I first
chose to become an entrepreneur my
friends my relatives my family members
started saying oh it's so great you're
so excited about becoming a millionaire
in all this other stuff
I tried becoming an entrepreneur too and
I feel wait you see how hard it is wait
to see how difficult it is you'll quit
as well people like your own is supposed
to make it right then I started making
six figures and then they said what
times you're working very hard right now
because you're single you have nothing
else to do alike wait till you see what
happens when you get married and you
have a wife you cannot work this hard so
then I got married and started a company
three months later in the insurance
industry in October of oh nine at a time
where no insurance company with given
contracts to anybody and then they said
well this is great it's just you and
your wife I mean life is easy you have
no other responsibilities there are no
kids then we had our first kid a couple
years later Patrick gabriel big david
said what was only one kid one kid is
very easy to have then we had our second
kid Dylan James where David looks very
easy you got two kids three kids it's
really hard because you're playing
triangle offense and zoning then we had
our third kid center Rose with David my
point to you is this kill today I'm
still engaged I'm hungrier I love my
family I love my kids I love my business
I love the country I live in I love the
blood I agree I love exactly what I'm
doing today and this is my message to
you majority of people around you are
looking for one thing and you cannot do
this they like to justify why they're
not winning they like to blame why
they're not winning and they like to
make excuses while they're not winning
and they're going to do whatever they
can to sell you on that you they're
gonna try to convince you why you should
quit and why life is going to be harder
and my message to you is you keep the
blinders on don't look at anybody focus
on the bigger picture could be your wife
your kids your family your dreams your
like your bloodline your mom your dad
your chip the reason when you wake up
looking at yourself in the mirror saying
I want to prove to myself I don't want
to justify
don't want to learn I don't want to make
excuses and then when you go out in one
big you know what all those people
that's anything you're going to say to
you they're going to say those magical
words you know what it is we always knew
we always knew immediately but behind
closed doors is so disconnected you do
if you justify
[Music]